die ukrainische Armee sie holt sich
immer mehr Land zurück schnell und
kraftvoll so beschreibt es
ukraine-präsident selensky schnell und
kraftvoll unser Bildreporter
pauronsheimer der ist genau dort
unterwegs im Moment in den Dörfern die
sich die Ukraine gerade erst
zurückgeholt hat und der sieht dort zwei
Dinge die große Erleichterung dass das
zu Hause nicht mehr von Russen besetzt
ist und gleichzeitig dann der Schrecken
über die Kriegsverbrechen den diese
Dörfer die Menschen dort jetzt
monatelang ausgesetzt waren Dorfbewohner
die Paul von Plünderungen erzählen von
besoffenen russischen Soldaten die die
Häuser ausrauben die Menschen dort
verschleppen paurons haben wir jetzt bei
uns in dieser Sendung ich grüße dich
Paul was sind das für Verbrechen von
denen dir die Menschen dort in diesen
Dörfern erzählen
ist es immer wieder ja dramatisch das zu
hören was die Menschen dort berichten es
ist eine völlig wahllose Verhaftung die
dort stattgefunden haben und haben die
Menschen in diesem Dorf was erst gestern
befreit worden ist berichtet dass
besoffene Soldaten umgeschossen haben in
Fenster uns wurde berichtet dass
einzelne Männer die man verdächtigt hat
der ukrainischen Armee nahe zu sein bzw
in der Vergangenheit für die ukrainische
Armee gekämpft zu haben dass man diese
mitgenommen habe es gibt weitere
Berichte darüber dass sie dann gefoltert
und erschossen worden sein sollen in
diesen Dörfern kommt der ganze Horror
dieses Krieges auf und es wird deutlich
kalt warum und das muss man ganz klar
sagen für die Ukraine gar keine andere
Wahl ist als ein Dorf nach dem anderen
zu versuchen zurück zu erobern jetzt ist
die Meldung bei uns ja ankommt so die
Dörfer werden zurückgeholt die
ukrainische Arme wie der Präsident sagt
auch rückt schnell und kraftvoll voran
aber gibt es diese dieses alte Leben für
diese Menschen dort überhaupt noch wenn
ja jetzt monatelang dort Schrecken
geherrscht hat
es sind absolut verrückte Geschichten
die man dort hört zum Beispiel haben wir
einen Wrestler getroffen einen
professionellen Wrestler der auch bei
der Europameisterschaft dabei war und
der hat uns erzählt dass er eigentlich
trainieren wollte und dann seit April
kein Internet mehr hatte weil die Russen
alles kaputt geschossen haben und alle
dachten er sei tot und jetzt in diesen
Tagen hat er sich das erste mal wieder
bei seinen Freunden bei seinen
Trainingspartnern in Kiew melden können
und gesagt hat ich bin übrigens am Leben
also viele Menschen erwachen in der
ganzen Ukraine und hören in diesen Tagen
ja mein Freund mein Verwandter meine
Frau meine Großeltern die Leben
tatsächlich denn da gab es gar keine
Kommunikation also das ist das erste was
die Menschen machen da gibt es ein
Starling von Elon Musk absurderweise in
diesen Dörfern und dann kann man das
erste Mal wieder sagen und all seinen
Liebsten schreiben dass man tatsächlich
am Leben ist ansonsten ist in vielen
Dörfern nicht mehr viel übrig da sind
viele geschlossene Gebäude und da sind
vor allem im Kopf der menschenkai
Geschichten die sie nie vergessen werden
und mit denen man wohl auch nur schwer
klar kommt du bist jetzt wieder dort
seit Tagen unterwegs in diesen Gebieten
die sich die ukrainische Armee gerade
zurückgekämpft hat wie groß ist diese
Region die jetzt wieder Ukraine geworden
ist also wie schnell und wie kraftvoll
kommt die Armee tatsächlich dort voran
tatsächlich ist die Region sehr groß
aber viele Dörfer da sind nicht mehr
viele Menschen sie sind entweder
geflohen oder gestorben oder sind in ja
andere
Regionen gegangen aber insgesamt von der
Quadratmeterzahl ist es ein riesiges
Gebiet also hier in Raki zum Beispiel
war das zweieinhalb Mal London in der
Region dass man zurückerobert hat vom
von der von der quadratkilometerzahl und
auch im Süden kommt man voran das ist
die Region rund um Croissant das ist
eine weitere Region die Putin sich
einverleiben will wo er gesagt hat das
ist jetzt russisch mit einem
scheinreferendum allerdings gehört zur
Wahrheit auch dazu dass die große Stadt
zum Beispiel Carson und weitere größere
Städte in russischer Hand weiterhin sind
und das noch lange dauern wird so geht
man davon aus bis man tatsächlich dort
diese Stadt diese Großstadt erobern kann
jetzt sagt
ukrainespräsident selenski in Richtung
von Vladimir Putin mit dir nicht
Wladimir Putin mit dir werde ich nicht
verhandeln das schließt er aus
Verhandlungen mit Putins Russland ich
habe mich gefragt ist das strategisch
die richtige Aussage die richtige
Entscheidung was ist deine Antwort
darüber habe ich auch nachgedacht kai
und ich glaube man sollte in so einer
Situation nie irgendetwas wirklich
ausschließen es ist ja noch einmal
Unterschied ob man sagt zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt mit den Bedingungen kann man
nicht verhandeln also
Putin oder Russland müsste eben diese
Truppen rausziehen aus dem Land aber
selensky macht da jetzt eine Härte und
eine sozusagen
Distanzierung und sagt ganz klar niemals
mit Putin und versucht dadurch
strategisch Druck zu machen auf das
Regime ob das funktioniert das halte ich
für fraglich
in die Gebiete die sich die ukrainische
Armee jetzt gerade Stück für Stück
zurück erkämpft danke dir Paul
[Musik]